Thank you for waiting.
Now, the 2016 edition of the Kagamibiraki ceremony of the Aikikai foundation will begin.
We will begin by a speech by Aikido Doshu, Ueshiba Moriteru.
Happy new year everybody.
I am very grateful to see that so many people gathered today
to celebrate together this Kagamibiraki of the Aikikai Hombu Dojo.
From the bottom of my heart, I wish to thank you very much.
It is generally accepted that Aikido has been going for 60 years.
Since then, Aikido has spread tremendously and it is now present in 130 countries.
Of course, it is the pursuit of the dynamic created by the founder Morihei Ueshiba
and continued by the second Doshu, Kisshomaru Ueshiba,
supported by your sincerity in practice, which has allowed the creation of such harmony.
From now also, I want to continue this great feeling of Aikido for the ages to come.
Take advantage of the spirit of Aikido
to contribute in enhancing oneself and society.
To do this, we must appreciate everyday's practice.
I want this approach to Aikido practice to continue this year.
Thank you very much.